[Music]
Michigan is now the first Midwestern
state to legally allow recreational
marijuana a new law took effect
overnight Michigan is the tenth state to
legalize recreational pot which is also
legal in Washington DC
Nicky batiste is at a medical marijuana
facility in Detroit with what some say
could make Michigan's law especially
dangerous make you good morning to you
good morning it could take a year before
Michigan starts licensing marijuana
shops like this one to sell to
recreational users critics worry the
wait could lead to high demand on the
black market where there's no oversight
starting today you can legally carry two
and a half ounces of pot that's roughly
what's in this jar and some say it's too
much is a little different Stewart
Carter showed us their products at his
medical marijuana shop in Detroit do you
think people are going to show up at
your door we've had people show up
unfortunately had to turn them down
Carter says he is eager to sell
recreational marijuana at the store but
the state is requiring shops to go
through a lengthy application process
you don't think you'll be able to sell
recreationally until 2020 they're not
going to take applications for about a
year and then there's going to be the
vetting process though people will have
to wait to buy recreational pot in
stores the new law allows people 21 or
older to keep 10 ounces in their home
and grow 12 marijuana plants for
personal use a single plant can produce
a bag of pot roughly this size it's
gonna be the marijuana capital of
America
Scott Greenlee as president of healthy
and productive Michigan he opposes
Michigan's high possession limit
allowing people to carry up to two and a
half ounces you can carry this in
Michigan it's the largest recreational
carry limit in the country that's too
much that's gonna leave do a lot of
crime as well people are gonna realize
that you know all of this product is
sitting around our law enforcement
community is very concerned about is all
that marijuana in those large quantities
the new law may be good news were
low-level pot offender
more than 20,000 people were arrested
last year in Michigan for marijuana
possession or use that is now legal
California legalized recreational pot
use in 2016
since then San Francisco district
attorney George Gascon has cleared over
a thousand misdemeanor marijuana cases
quite frankly can impact your ability to
get employment minor charges Gascon
believes can have a major impact in some
places that will impact your ability to
get public housing we're getting
subsidized housing it may impact your
ability to go into military services but
Greenlee says most low-level offenders
don't face severe consequences typically
what's being dismissed is a ticket a
fine it's very similar to if we're going
15 miles and over on the speed limit you
know we'll we'll get a ticket we'll pay
our ticket and we'll move on one county
prosecutor in michigan told CBS News
he's already dismissed 50 pending cases
for misdemeanor marijuana offenders that
are no longer illegal as of today under
the new law it is still illegal to use
pot in public on college campuses and
while driving Nora well that seems
reasonable
Nicki thank you